one of these i used to be like yeah i
want to go travel all the time but i'm
also just like at home is a blessing
[Music]
passenger party of five copies
good morning and happy what's today
friday
happy friday it's friday we're in uh new
york city very rainy
we're taking a week
vacation
in new england to enjoy
the fall colors
very excited for the week ahead
we're gonna spend a few days here in new
york
and then we're gonna drive to
connecticut
and then we're gonna drive to boston
all in one week and it should be fun
look at that tree
it's so yellow
[Music]
yes
east coast even though we moved here
like a couple weeks ago
[Music]
[Applause]
so
on part two of our new england trip
we're going through all these different
towns that i lived in oh yeah this is
new england
before i moved to san diego
i lived a lot on the east coast and so
now i'm taking scots all the little
towns and houses that i grew up in
and luckily
the foliage is still here so it's
gorgeous
it's a nice break from the hustle and
bustle of the city
nice scott
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
what do you think of connecticut
cold it's cold it's like
46 degrees or something it's so pretty
though
it's so pretty
so
[Music]
happy
friday everybody
oh it's quite cold
i'm glad he's having so much fun so
we've been traveling a lot and we went
to
new york as you just saw for about a
week like east coast new england
and then basically a week after that we
went to the bay area because scott's
company holiday party happened and stuff
now we're just chilling i don't have any
other travel plans in the future which
feels nice i feel like when i was like
in my earlier 20s i used to be like yeah
i want to go travel all the time and go
see things and of course covet has
affected
a lot of my feelings towards that but
i'm also just like dude
being at home for like two or three
straight months is a blessing yeah like
i really don't have any travel plans at
all so
i'm i'm feeling great granted i know
that there is gonna be travel next year
2022 and stuff but for now i'm excited
to just enjoy the holiday season at home
ellie's also sleeping here too
this is the doggo
nap room in the afternoon because it
becomes very warm and i'm here and
sometimes i give them treats which is
probably more of why they're here
working with dogs nearby
i recommend
happy sunday we're in line to get gas at
costco because gas is so expensive are
gonna go christmas tree shopping today
with our friends there's like a
christmas tree farm
in east county-ish we usually get our
christmas tree from just like home
improvement store a lot
but this year we found out about this
christmas tree lot that also has like
wine and petting zoo
and you get to chop down your own tree
so we thought it'd be fun to check it
out with some friends so we're gonna do
that today
[Applause]
so many christmas trees
[Music]
what about this one
is it too
tall what about that one scott
oh these these little ones are really
little they're like charlie brown trees
we lost their friends
but we see them because there's a little
bit of red right there about what do you
think of these christmas trees they're
cool
they're cute they're very cute do you
want to see my bookmark yeah
i bark marked it i don't know if i can
find it again
but i put a bark on it you put a bark on
it yeah
what does that even mean you'll see what
you see
[Music]
they all look the same the bark wanted
to fall into my yeah
we can find a new bark mark street i
don't think is this real because i feel
like i've passed this riff so many times
already
where
oh oh oh maybe this oh fell off from it
oh maybe it did fall
maybe we probably brushed against it i
kind of like this one this one this
one's also very tall very thin the parts
that look kind of bare you should just
tie this to it
yeah maybe we should people mark them
instead
scott's doing the recruiting
yeah i think this is good we found it i
think so
yay
[Applause]
[Music]
you're a cutie
are you protecting all the trees
[Music]
look who's still sleeping in bed little
miss you didn't get up this morning a
lot of people don't know that i have a
cat
because she doesn't make an appearance
nearly as much as the dogs
but i do
this is benny
we've had her for
like
four or five years or something
we got her when we got engaged she's
kind of mean though sometimes she's
being really loving right now but a lot
of times she bites that out of my hand
happy tuesday everybody
we are like a week away a week and a
half away from christmas i'm not done
with my holiday shopping
yet and christmas is coming up a lot
faster
than i thought it would which is always
what happens and i always think to
myself when you go
you gotta get done earlier next year
because you have an entire like three or
four weeks to plan it and then
inevitably like the last week of
christmas i'm just like
you know
forgot to do all of it hi ellie but yeah
anyway
this is the last vlog of the year so
thank you all so much for sticking
around being here
watching a bunch of my videos this year
i had a blast uh making videos this is
the first year that i did youtube full
time the whole year round and there are
a lot of videos that i really enjoyed
making just to call out a couple of my
favorite videos because i am very proud
of these ones i think the hustle culture
one
definitely like that's one of my like
greatest hits i'm very proud of that
video i didn't think that it would get
the reception that it did but it did and
i'm i'm really happy about that like
honestly more than anything glad to hear
that i i'm not alone in those thoughts
and feeling like hustle culture isn't
for me and for a lot of people so that's
one and then the other one is what
happened to japan's tech industry
because that's just something to me
that's like me in a video like i get to
bring all these different parts of
myself i'm japanese and american and
i've experienced the tech industry in
america but what about japan is that an
option has that ever been an option if
so what does it look like so it was
really fun to kind of explore that in
that video and talk to people who are
doing that like working in the tech
industry in japan so if you haven't
checked them out i'll leave cards right
here to do so but thank you all so much
for watching and supporting this year my
team and i have been brainstorming a lot
of videos that we want to make for next
year and so we're really excited for
what's to come there's just going to be
better bigger awesomer cooler chiller
things that are going to come out so i
hope you stick around for that you know
more excited than anything to learn more
about stuff and myself and the world and
things speaking of learning thank you so
much for brilliant for sponsoring
today's video also thank you to
brilliant for sponsoring like a video a
month this year they've been an
outstanding sponsor to work with and
they let me do what i do so if you're
not familiar with brilliant brilliant is
an interactive learning platform that
enables you to learn math science and
computer science concepts in fun
hands-on ways their whole kind of like
methodology with learning is that the
best way to learn something is to do it
and so they add a ton of interactivity
to all their different courses that
makes it really easy to visualize and
internalize the concepts in them so
whether you want to brush up on computer
science fundamentals like algorithms or
making decisions you want to improve on
your logical reasoning by taking their
brand new logic course or you really
want to understand what a derivative is
through their calculus in a nutshell
course they've got everything for you so
you can get 20 off brilliant annual
proven subscription if you're one of the
first 200 people to click the link below
in the description box whether the
subscription is for you or your friend
or a loved one then make sure to level
up your learning with brilliant today
thank you so much again to brilliant for
sponsoring this is the end of the vlog
the end of vlogs for 2021 there will be
more vlogs in 2022 so make sure to hit
subscribe if you haven't done so already
leave a comment down below letting me
know what your favorite video was of
mine or what videos you want to see in
the future anyway hope you all have a
wonderful and safe and cozy holiday
season and i'll see you next year bye
[Music]